everybody welcome to life coding with
Jessie today we're gonna get back to
work on the main website for Franciscan
the University I work for sorry I was a
few minutes late
I turn it on the stream and I started
dropping frames so let me know how the
video is I tried turning off a few a few
programs that I was working with earlier
that I don't need so hopefully hopefully
everything will work I was just looking
to see if there's anything else I could
turn off I don't think I can all right
looks like the videos fine hey everybody
alright so a little update on some of
the projects I think I have for the
catechetical Institute site for now I
think everything's completed I'm just
waiting on some content before I make
those changes live I hope that comes in
soon because we also updated all our
packages and some of those packages that
are currently on there are pretty old so
I'd love to move to the new updated
branch as soon as I can
the stuff for the bulletin if you
remember I've been talking about the
university bulletin that I think is it's
like you have to log in to get into it
which i think is unnecessary but
basically they're still going to be a
login so that's not gonna change for now
but we made it a little bit easier and
was it yesterday stream I think we made
it easier to get in so I think that'll
be fine it'll take care of most of the
issues
that some of the users were having and
the JavaScript AF site works being done
on that so javascript sir that was in
here yesterday is doing some design work
building out a little bit of the the
front end and just some basic HTML
Harshit is working on the the server or
the api so maybe we'll have something to
see with that you know maybe hopefully
soon I'm not gonna be able to work that
much on it because this projects gonna
take up a ton of my time I'm preparing
to you know work over over my normal
amount of time on this this morning I
was just doing a lot of migrating data
and who looks like the stream cut the
black for a second is it all right now
all right cool
so anyway I was trying to migrate a
bunch of data and some like my eyes are
just so dry after staring at the the
screen and anyway I'm glad to get back
to doing some like front-end work my
co-workers are looking in the door
alright so let me check the live chat
quickly just to say hello and see if
there's any questions I should answer
right away and then I'll show my screen
and we'll get started let's see all
right looks like a strange fun for most
of you Stephen says today Jesse will be
discussing beard care and the two
buttons shirt rule ready go I did have
my beard trimmed up a little bit when I
got a haircut so it's freighting less
scruffy than normal all right
okay harsh it's adding commits to the PR
I'll check out those PRS after the
stream
alright let's switch it up okay let me
start my timer and we'll bring over our
projects so I have updated this project
this Franciscan react is the repo name
I've updated this project too based on
the pool request and I don't think
there's any outstanding pool requests
right now that are completed so I
shouldn't we should be up to date I'm
gonna double check though
yep all the pool requests are in alright
so some of the additions we have are the
search the search animation works here
which is awesome and I believe we went
over yeah we went over this I mean
yesterday I have some additions here we
have a different color here so pretty
good I'm happy about that and the pool
requests were mainly so rook or nikki
has added that search toggle and also
those links that we just saw on the
drawer also added committees in so when
we go to do a commit I'm gonna try out
this new way we're doing commits that
should help have like a standard for for
committing to get so we'll see how that
works I think it'll be it'll take some
getting used to at first but in the long
run it should be should be better all
right if I missed any PRS I'm sorry let
me know and I'll I will give you credit
for
any PRS let's see
let's see probably five days
all right just double-checking the
lights out again so today we want to fix
some stuff with the mobile the mobile
view I'd mention maybe yesterday that it
looks I hadn't kept in mind at all the
the mobile view of this and I I don't
know why because we should be thinking
mobile first based on the audience which
is going to be primarily teenagers so
today we're gonna try to clean this up
and have it be acceptable for mobile I
mean you can see right now this is just
I think it's just ridiculous so bad and
that's I mean that's my fault
Wow okay let's start up here with with
the header first thing I'd like to do is
really remove all of this I'm just gonna
remove everything for the mobile version
of the header the only thing I might
even consider keeping is a call to
action but I don't think I'll keep that
a thing I'm just gonna get rid of get
rid of all of it and then see how it
looks if it looks like we might have
space to add anything in maybe but we'll
check it out we'll see how it goes I'm
not worried about the links right so we
have all the links here so mobile users
aren't missing out on anything
they'll snowball the same content the
only thing that'll be missing is you
know this access fus and button and then
these social icons
maybe we can add those in here somewhere
we'll see I could maybe access fus yeah
we'll see maybe we'll add them in the
side
but first things first let's just get
them out of here all right so oops wrong
code so let's check up I don't need this
right now
do we need to let's keep the drawer up
I'm not making any queries all right so
our app bar is where we're gonna be
working at for now so for all these SVG
icons I suppose we're just going to take
care of this with a media query Stephen
says I should do a social drop-down
that's interesting idea we'll think
about that you say maybe like up in the
corner here just have a small icon it
can drop down I kind of yeah I'll think
about that all right so let's add let's
just add in a class here and let's go
just uh only yeah let's call it desktop
only I mean really this will probably
end up being the case for oh no I can't
do it in here I need this to be like in
a media query I don't think we can do
media queries in an object like this
right well that's interesting I've I've
never come across the the case where I
need to make a media query when I was
doing this that's really weird
I wonder if I wonder if it's your UI has
anything built in that I could be using
before we make our own it would probably
be I guess it would be the fastest just
to make our own but I I do want to check
oh all right Aniki says that's why I had
trouble with mobile styles in that pull
request no media queries all right well
let's let's see what we can do
I don't need pretty much any of this
stuff right now
I'm Seri lie let's see
layouts hidden area here we are ok looks
like we have some breakpoints release
beta 34 break oh they're breaking
changes in beta 30 alright cool
off to check that out I open that in a
new tab for now all the mounts are
visible unless they are explicitly
hidden universe' ranger grateful
all right so they're bringing in
importing hidden and then let's see what
using it they're just wrapping hidden
okay so wrapping the component and
hidden so let's see I'll probably give
the children will be hidden at or above
we won't want the up we want it down
probably most likely for what we're
doing here
so maybe medium and down
then we double-check the live chat see
if missing anything
all right cool harsha do is mentioning
that there's that hide component alright
cool well let's let's do that let's grab
our hidden will import hidden and bring
it in up here oops I'm sorry this is so
small I was working earlier so I had it
really small sorry about that
hopefully straining your eyes to see
that tiny tiny text alright so now let's
wrap something in hidden and see if it
will work I may as well just copy what
they did here so I'm gonna try medium
and down I think that'll work
I'm gonna move this over a bit we don't
need it so let's see what this is to our
icon I want that we went to title we
went to logo and all this this whole
grid well yeah everything within this
grid I think we can get rid of so let me
double check the grid here see where we
had it yep so we can put hidden here and
then down here sorry if I'm scrolling
really fast I hope I didn't make anybody
motion sick hidden woah oh it's just
indentation we'll save it there we are
okay let's see what happened
wonderful okay that worked the the top
have had really really thin I think it
could use a bit of padding at the top
but I mean that's it basically worked it
did what we wanted to do now that I look
at it if we keep the logo this size
which I think is is fine that size works
especially for a small screen then we
may have some space over here I do want
to check to see what this is 400 all
right let me let me shrink this down a
bit so if we dock dev tools here we can
actually shrink the screen down a bit
more so I think 320 is the smallest
screen so that's about 320 yeah so if we
were to add something in here it would
definitely have to be something very
small so I say I'm not gonna add
anything for right now and we'll see
later on at this point let's just keep
it simple we need to launch this thing
we can always add more in later on and
the only thing that I'm thinking of is
would it be better to Center this logo
now that there's nothing over here or
should we keep it aligned over here let
me know in the live chat I'm not going
to do anything with it now on a larger
screen it definitely looks whoa all
right okay so medium is all the way up
there let's see it where that breakpoint
you know what it doesn't the brief only
doesn't just happen like normal and CSS
so what is that 1212
it's like 1280 or something is the
breakpoint huh let's try to drop that
down I think we might be able to drop
down to the next breakpoint and it would
still work so let me double check what
that is called ASM so let's change it SM
and oops alright let's see how far down
this will go whoops okay yeah that
definitely works that works okay I like
that not that's a great point that's
more around nine of what is that nine
sixty nine ninety somewhere around there
we're get another ninety yeah I think
that's much more reasonable I don't
think we could go any lower than that
actually there's only one break point
lower than that so I think that's that's
really all we can do anyway but I think
that's fine that's that's definitely
acceptable really we definitely can't
fit very many more options up here which
is okay with me I don't want to clutter
this up let's see what happens when we
expand this
all right good that still works let me
shrink it down a bit more all right
great
so I don't I was worried we'd run into
issues with expanding this but it looks
like we have enough space awesome
awesome
all right cool so that that works now I
do want to double check you know what we
still have a little bit I can still
scroll horizontally a bit so we have
something else that's that's messing
this up it wasn't just the the header
visit this it's gotta be yeah it's gotta
be this let's check this out
hmm
that's got some weird stuff going on
all right well I'd say if we are going
to have cards like this with that much
text yeah we got to change it so
internally these need to stack I suppose
they either need to stack or these
always need to be you know a hundred
percent with if we get down lower
something has to happen there I'm gonna
check the live chat quickly just to see
if if you all had any any advice all
right I just want to take a moment to
think about what I want to do with this
type of thing I know we're gonna utilize
these on the home page let's see all
right so would it look better if we
stack these so that the image was on top
I don't know really know that I like a
circular image on the top like that
you know we may have to go we had just
used the the existing I think it was a
list component to do this and we just
made one item in the list we may have to
do something you know more custom to
have some more control over this that
probably went up being easier than
trying to modify the list component
directly
yeah for now let's see if we go see how
it looks when it's like this
all right you know what I still really
don't like that look so this type of
card I think only looks alright the way
we have it with just the right amount of
tags just the right size I want to think
of something a little more versatile for
this because we needed to look good on
different sizes rook says or Nikki says
can you use shape outside CSS when it's
a small card makes it look like
magazines with text around an image oh
that's a really good idea if we're gonna
do that though I think we probably will
have to make a custom card so let's
I guess we could try that out
yeah
alright let's try it out let's I want to
do something with this though as well on
a smaller screens so it's I don't want
it you know I'm like a screen this size
I don't think it looks right to just
have this all the way up against the
edge like that so let's do something
with this first I'm just kind of like
working my way down so I don't want to
skip this and go to the cars right now I
mean we could we center this what is
this is this
yeah a text-align:center works yeah I
mean that works good
okay yeah text-align:center is fine for
that it's nice when the answer is so
simple alright so we're gonna put that
oh I'm up in the app bar I need to go to
let's close this index page
here we are
so here should we do it I guess we could
make a clasp for it
flex innocent 80 or things kind of well
we could just add it onto here I mean
this has a lot of really specific things
so it's not like we're gonna reuse it so
let's just add it onto here oops
[Music]
Center all right I'm gonna double check
just to make sure I clear out anything
in dev tools
all right cool that works awesome all
right now let's work our way down the
page I want to try to remember to keep
this small okay
those buttons are an acceptable size
there I think I can live with that
yeah and this what size is this yeah
this is just we're gonna need to do
something with fonts as well I mean even
on that this is like the simplest type
of card you can make it's just a card
with text on it
even there we're leaking over the edges
so more marius says why not use the
mobile view simulator thingy I don't I
don't like them okay
be honest with you I do use it sometimes
but I I'd like to do this better I like
to just you know move this back and
forth and see what happens so it does
have its its uses but just not I don't
know I like this better in case you're
not sure what we're talking about we can
toggle this mobile view and like we
could change it and say like our let's
check out an iPhone 4 right and this
would be iPhone 4 view you can see what
it would look like on our iPhone 4 click
scroll you could change the you should
be able to change mobile there was a
button for like landscape mode and
portrait mode I don't know what happened
to that button seems like the UI for
this has changed huh
I for I don't know it doesn't really
matter but anyway this is nice if you
want to check it on a specific device
and you don't have that device then
anyway yeah Nikki says yeah you use the
ability to play with it with good point
I hadn't thought about it that way yet
yeah yeah I mean it's just uh you know
like this I can see like okay exactly
the point where things shift that helps
me especially if I'm trying to write
media queries myself like I need to know
the the real like pixel number exactly
and I don't want to be switching trying
to find phones that have that pixel
value but it does really come in handy
if you like if let's say you don't have
something like browserstack where you
can simulate phones you could use this
and at least get you know something that
could be useful all right my timer ran
out so I'm gonna take a short break from
coding now go to the live chat and
answer some of your questions
there's a question about what does the
p5 d25 mean and it was answered in live
chat but I just want to answer that
again in case you're watching later on
it's project 5 day 25 so I've tried I
don't think I have it for every video
but some of the early ones I didn't do
this but for most of the videos it has
what project it is and what day it is
and I abbreviate it so we don't have
really long titles but then that way if
you want to go back and watch things
like in order you can kind of easily
tell what where we're at in the series
Antonio says hi hey how's it going
thanks for watching
see
all right it looks like Harsha and
Marius is saying you can actually move
back and forth in that mode let's check
that up so it's not responsive mode oh
nice
I didn't know that I liked it yeah I
like that
then you could do this too oh-ho I
actually really like that that's cool
maybe I'll try this
I'll try this mode out for the rest of
the stream you all convince me I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna try it out
what
do you see that what what is that veneer
yeah these cards are not gonna work we
we gotta redo those Wow
that dog is just too cute all right well
there wasn't really very many questions
I kind of looked back into the live chat
a lot more than I normally do so kept up
with things so I guess I'll just we'll
go back in here and let's I don't know
get rid of these cards or you know make
something else we had to do something
about this because that's that's pretty
bad we can also check on some of our
interior pages I don't think there'll be
a problem with the interior pages but
you never know some of the mark-up that
we're importing may have some weird
stuff going on so it's worth we can
obviously can't check every piece of
content but maybe we could check you
know one or two examples of each type
let's see Nicki says that whitespace is
caused by elements that are taken out of
the document flow like position:absolute
elements that that could make sense
because we're using you know masonry so
that is still in positioning absolute
but the element itself looks fine it's
just the the insides of it that are
getting messed up
alright let's take a closer look at
what's going on now
Wow harsh it already has eight tasks
done in the JavaScript AF API repo if if
you all want to check out what's going
on with that project it's in my
repositories so the stuff we I do for
work is in the fu s marcom organization
if you check my profile just I think
it's Jesse or Weigel that's where the
the new stuff is
harsh janessa says you need standard J s
and the repo yeah I'd like to do it just
like we set up our projects here you
know like prettier husky standard J s
uzs lint think what else we do I mean
obviously we want to use testing so I'd
like to keep it you know keep it the
same and then depending on how it goes
with using committees in I think we we
might want to use that as well I want to
make it as easy as possible for people
to contribute but also keep everything
you know the same in terms of style I
think it'll just make it a lot easier
oh look ask for n Grogg sorry sorry
Nicki I totally forgot about Endre let
me get that up and running for you all
so if you haven't seen me use this
before if you click this link that I
just paste it into the live chat you can
see this website as we're working on it
and you can go into dev tools just like
like I'm knowing and check everything
out all right is this the this is the
container
I wonder if we mess with overflow let's
mess with the overflow alright so let's
see if we can I mean we can do something
like this which at least should prevents
what should prevent all this weirdness
from happening but then we don't see any
of the content so that's not an ideal
and it fixes one problem it makes
another so we may end up putting that on
there just in case something weird
happens and content sticks out so it
doesn't mess up the whole page it just
messes up that piece of content John
Ensign says hey Oh watch this lady your
busy day here oh hey John thanks for
stepping checking in alright so it looks
like let me take this off for a second
so we can see area
yet let's rebuild this card
all right we're gonna rebuild the card
we want to make a card then that we
could probably do with making the font a
little smaller
he
so really this is what we came from and
we just made it really big so I wouldn't
want to shrink this down to that size
just to make it fit
he
I actually I don't even remember what I
did to change this so let's go in and
see what we did so should be should
still be in the index and remember we
hard-coded a bunch of these cards in
here we're not gonna leave it like this
so it looks a little crazy now but this
will all get taken care of
so YouTube embeds where's there we are
okay alright so we gave it an avatar big
in list item text big all right let's
check it out you know what I gave this
this avatar a fixed width and height
which that's that's an issue
hmm
hmm
I guess we could try to shrink this
hmm
I'm really I'm really kind of undecided
here
John Anson says 100% with four cards get
rid of image
right now that I look at this I mean it
won't fix our problem but it'll help do
we really need this much margin on the
sides where are we getting all that
margin from oh because I put the margin
in okay
under what we had before I mean that's
that's definitely more acceptable see
what it looks like on a larger screen
yeah I am I think I'm going to remove
that margin for that padding I mean
sorry let's make sure that that is he
record yeah let's take that out all
right this will give us a little bit
more realistic picture of how much space
we have to deal with all right so as
expected we still have this issue maybe
we could just and this is a I think what
John was saying is yeah this is what
John was saying let's just get rid of
the image on small screens what so I
mean let's see what it looks like
yeah I mean this looks exactly how I
wanted it to look and expected it to
look when it has enough space but say
probably anything beyond this so was it
nine
let's try small and down let's hide this
one's falling down if we can and I'll be
realistically we're gonna have more text
than this
let's go on the site now and and find a
comparable piece of content just to get
a realistic view of how much text is
gonna be in these cars
so slow I Wow all right so right now we
aren't giving more information we just
have a little quote I guess with a link
okay will quote with a link let's see if
we have I think we do have let's check
these pages I know somewhere in the site
we have little sections like that that
with the picture and text the islands
check the accounting department see
what's here all right so this is how
we're doing this student 1 so this is
the amount of text that we have and but
we still have a read more link all right
then we have a bigger profile
all right so I guess we're fine we can
deal with just having this amount of
text it seems like we are just using a
link to get people you know we just have
a small amount of text okay
all right Nikki Nikki see you later
thanks for watching thanks for all your
help okay then a thermo timer yeah I did
all right I suppose then what we could
try to do is have have the fonts an
image then just get smaller for a small
screen
let's just try that at first this is one
of those things where I I hate I think
I've already spent too much time on it
because no matter what I do here
it could change dramatically when I
actually start showing it to people here
where I work and get different ideas so
I think I'm just kind of stressing over
you know really unnecessarily at this
point but let's let's go in here the the
big thing is I need to be able to change
these classes based on a break point so
let's see we're in mom it's here you
like the area so I don't need hidden I
need these break points though
heeey
all right that's interesting this is
kind of our problem here
alright I'll keep that in mind
alright responsive breakpoints wonderful
see how this works
whoa
very cool I had no idea there were
breakpoints built into here all right
let's try it out so we are going to
within Syria
maybe avatar so within this avatar big
let's go
pain breakpoints now small let's drop
this down to 100 and let's drop this
down to
let's just let's get 24 all right see if
that works
I've never tried to do breakpoints with
material UI oh all right
pretty cool let's all right so we go
not bad not bad
Wow
all right it still there's some spots
where it's a little weird a lot weird
why is it still there I thought this
breakpoint was a lot oh because we have
it going like this
oops keep going the wrong way let's see
where we have this ever
[Music]
I'm gonna try like this and see what
difference that makes - so let's see we
go to this point
oops I did it on the wrong thing alright
so what I'm trying to do here is let me
search for there yeah
search for Thomas crow this is my boss
by the way and here I'm gonna change
this to medium and that should help make
things look a little better okay yeah
there we are so this is always gonna be
all the way across until we get up to a
more reasonable size alright so here
yeah not bad not that bad not perfect
but I think that's way more acceptable
than it was before it looked obviously
broken now I think it looks okay we
still have you know I can't zoom in in
here I'm gonna switch this up and toggle
back to this you so I can zoom in so we
still have this white area even on large
screens we have this white area and we
can so even on large screens I I have a
horizontal scrollbar over so like this
shouldn't happen see this site does not
have a horizontal scrollbar all right
let me check my time three minutes if
anybody has any idea why I have a
horizontal scrollbar still please let me
know in the live chat I know I've had
this same thing happened to me on
various projects throughout the years I
don't know why I can't remember what the
problem was before
all right so usually when this happens I
just go through and try to see which
elements are sticking out see it there
doesn't appear to be any let's go to the
top
Dave says start removing elements vishal
says hello a lot of love from india hey
Vishal thanks for joining us I have a
lot of love for India as well I have
quite a few of you from India that that
watched the show I mean based on the
analytics I think number one is from the
United States number two most viewers
thinker from the UK and then after that
is India then I really appreciate it
because I know the time zone because of
the time difference sometimes things can
be crazy for the live stream let's start
opening up some of these header all
right let's go
do we
all right so it's not in the header
let's check the footer the weight not in
the footer so at least we know it's in
the main main place here all right so we
can check
let's just get rid of this hero section
oh it's in the hero section awesome
alright let's refresh this and get to
hero section back now he can go in Dave
thank you so much for that that was so
helpful Dave suggested that I just start
removing elements and that was way
faster than what I was initially trying
to do all right so where's our header or
I'm sorry I hear a section here here's
our hero section
let's see where it's where it's at
what's going on
there we are it's right here
I thought it was that pairing
yeah but it's not the padding it still
does that
well I have this set on Macs with just
forgotten soon
see what's inside of here as well all
right it's nothing inside it's
definitely this alright my timer did run
out but I really him so close I really
want to figure this out before we end
the stream let me go to computed see
where I'm getting my width from all
right looks like it's calculated I'm
just gonna start removing Stiles
I already tried removing the padding
that didn't do anything
it's crazy
it's got to be padding
whoa-oh
let's go up on here with
all right maybe I added this
let's see where that's coming from
now let me actually look at this
you know a grid container alright so is
it this one yeah
yeah but
was it this grid container
oh no the screens freezing shoes let me
know is it freezing for everybody what's
what's going on but so anyway I think I
found the problem it's with this grid
right here this grid container
I'm not sure what to do about that so
I'm getting some Styles applied here
here mmm grid type container so it's not
that it's a type container it's a
spacing
it's a spacing one
special issue system
maybe I'm not gonna be able to use grid
for just two
see if I can just override it
what all right that fixed it alright so
I'm not sure what was going on with that
but I just put an inline style which
would override the other styles and made
a width of 100% let me move the screen
about a little bit just to make sure
that thinks they'll work no I'll never
see a screen that small what am I
thinking
let's get its feet more reasonable here
all right all right cool so that was
another really easy fix I'm gonna keep
trying to work within like the material
you I you know documentation but
sometimes it's just so easy to fix it
with a little in lifestyle so now
normally if we are gonna reuse this
component a lot of places I might think
twice about doing that but this is the
hero section it's only gonna exist on
the front page so I'm gonna do it once
and it's it's only gonna have to be once
if I end up having a similar problem on
other pages then maybe we can dig deeper
and look into it but I think that was a
pretty simple fix so at this point at
least the home page now doesn't have any
glaring layout errors on mobile so
mission accomplished for today let's
commit this and put it up to github so
let's go get status get status and
looks good yeah that's what we wanted to
check I had the yarn lock updated from
when I was bringing merging pool
requests earlier all right so I want to
use this new this new thing that Nicky
put in here what is it commit is in so
let's see how I use this all right so
let's try yarn run cm
oops I forgot to get it get a yarn see
em alright so now when we do committin
you can see I can just move up and down
with my arrow keys and select what kind
of commit I want to do so
I mean maybe a fix
all right let's do a fix component or
file name we could do at bar
in short imperative tense description I
would say
horizontal scroll the skin let's see
all right so I just wanted to like do a
large example here but I don't expect
you all to write out that much if you
want to you know if you want to make a
commit message in fact like the long
message I don't need that at all in the
commit
I mean odds are you're going to be
submitting a pull request and you're
gonna put the description in your pull
request but basically probably the first
part right what kind of commit this is
and then the third part a short
description that's all you really need
the other stuff does help but it's not
mandatory
no breaking changes no I don't think so
we have any issues I don't think we have
the issue up and for that
alright cool now it's gonna run all its
auto formatting linting and testing I
kind of hope it doesn't pass the test
just so we can see an example of what
happens but I think it will
cool with past greats now we can do get
push origin and everything is now on the
repo on github let's see Harshit says
merge my PR as well Harshit is that your
PR is there PR for this repo there you
mean for what is it the JavaScript AF
all right I'm just merging it right now
from the command line or I'm sorry from
github
all right I should I merged it
I didn't bother checking it out because
literally we had nothing in the project
I just had a readme a contributing MD
file did I even have that I had to read
me a license and maybe a contributing
file and that was it so obviously
whatever Asha does is not gonna break it
okay so now that we've got that
accomplished I'm gonna go to the live
chat get through all the questions read
out some comments so if you have
anything you want me to answer or
anybody else on the lab have to answer
please put it in there now let me scroll
to the top
someone in the lab chat said they are
high AF if you don't know what that
means
good for you if you do know what that
means don't do drugs that's the public
service announcement today from me um
I'm not not sure I'll let this person I
think that's it I think it's all day
they said and didn't make any more
comments got to see not really a lot of
questions
all right Louise says hi Jesse is this a
project that you're building the same as
the one on fu s Markham Franciscan react
on github yeah yeah this is it this is
that project and now that we've
committed the changes and push them up
to github it should be it's exactly the
same everything I have on my machine is
the same as what's on on github
Anmol says do we really need a degree to
get a web app developer job you do not
you don't need a degree it probably
depends a lot on what the what things
are like in your particular country or
wherever you're trying to get a job as
to whether it's kind of customary to
have a degree or not but here in the
United States if you're trying to get a
job with a tech company or maybe a small
startup having a degree is definitely
not mandatory it's possible that it
could help you if you have some sort of
undergraduate degree but it's it's not
mandatory most of the jobs that I see
they don't mention education at all they
just want to know your skills are but I
do see some that require some sort of
degree
ayyyy bows here hey Eva how's it going
davus how can I be part of this Dave you
can you do as much as you want in terms
of you know checkout the repos so we
have we have a lot of projects going on
right now mostly react stuff we have
this react project is our main thing
project that we're working on and that's
what we'll be talking about here on the
streams for at least another month but
we also have a react native project and
we have a react project where we're
using electron to make desktop apps so
depending on what you're interested in
you could work on those as well usually
I'll just create issues for these
different repositories you can find
links in the descriptions for the repos
and you could just take one of those
issues try to work on it submit a pull
request if you want if you'd rather not
you know contribute code but you just
like to contribute advice and help in
the live chat that's that's excellent
too if you want more info about that you
know ask more questions here or you can
message me on some social media platform
whatever you want but that's it I'm
missing some other way to contribute I
mean really help helping answer
questions and things the live chat and
then work and/or contributing code or
probably the main ways
Harshit says might clone the repo as
well I have a feeling that you haven't
cloned that you mean the repo I just
made yeah I haven't cloned that repo yet
I created it in github and didn't clone
it yet all right I've got another the
end of the live chat this was
surprisingly short live chat today
mostly because there weren't a lot of
questions there's a lot of discussion
during the chat about what we were going
to do which is awesome
I always appreciate that help okay we
got Evo says have you ever done
something with with Go Go laying I'm
currently thinking about doing some big
scale data processing and looking at
some solutions currently unfortunately I
have no experience with it so wish I
could be more help but I I know almost
nothing about it
so if anyone else here knows more about
go please let ebo know but yeah I I have
no idea
it's alright so that's the last question
here I today's all right yeah today's
Thursday so I should be back tomorrow
maybe sometime around noon 1:00 p.m.
something like that and that's my time
Eastern Sun and we're gonna come right
back here and be working on something
else I'll I will be busy migrating data
so I'm not exactly sure what we'll be
working on but I'm definitely not gonna
broadcast me migrating data cuz that's
super boring maybe we'll have some new
types of pages that will work on
depending on how much data I get over
but until then have a wonderful day